- It seemed like everyone and their mother
was advertising Established
Titles this year.
Is it a scam? Yes.
Is it illegal? Maybe.
Established titles has taken over YouTube.
It's extremely prominent.
YouTubers have run
sponsorships for the company,
and the money was flowing.
Like many YouTubers, I had
been approached repeatedly
about running an Established
Titles sponsorship.
- If it's not Scottish, it's crap!
- I declined because it
didn't make much sense to me
and started researching
my own video on the topic.
And that wasn't until Scott Schafer made
a video calling Established Titles a scam.
It pretty much blew up the internet.
This company is a complete scam.
So is established titles really a scam?
Well, that's what we're
gonna figure out here today.
Now, it's actually hard to explain
what Established Titles does
without already jumping
into value judgements.
So I'll let Established Titles
explain in its own words.
Established Titles owns less
than 200 acres of land in rural Scotland.
Their website says that you can buy
a dedicated one-foot by
one-foot square souvenir plot
of land from them.
And it also states that you can quote,
"Become a Lord or lady today."
They say that their packages are quote,
"Based on a historic Scottish
land ownership custom
where landowner have been
long referred to as lairds,
the Scottish term for lord,
with the female equivalent being lady."
Okay, so let's start at the beginning.
When you're talking
about false advertising,
or fraud in commerce,
you're probably talking
about one of two laws.
Section 43(A) of the Lanham
Act authorizes civil suits
for false advertising that quote,
"Misrepresents the nature,
characteristics, qualities,
or geographic origin,"
of goods or services.
States have their own laws
regulating false advertising
and other deceptive trade practices.
For example, California Business
and Professions Code 17-500,
aka False Advertising Law,
or the FAL, prohibits false
and misleading statements
generally in connection
with any goods, services, and/or
real or personal property.
Now to understand whether advertising
is false or misleading, you have to look
at the claims that are being made.
When it comes to established titles,
there are several different
sources of potential claims,
their website advertisements
and YouTube sponsorships.
And we'll look at each of those in turn.
(digital glass smashes)
Well, the homepage and
the hero banner states
that you can quote, "Save
the Scottish woodlands,"
and quote, "Become a Lord today."
A prior version of the website said,
"Become a Lord or lady today."
You can quote, "Purchase
a personal lordship
or ladyship title pack with
dedicated land in Scotland."
The asterisks direct you
to fine print right below.
It says, I quote, "This is a purchase
for a personal dedication
for a souvenir plot of land.
You may choose to title yourself
with a title of lord, laird, or lady."
And as I said before,
the website states quote,
"This is based on a historic
Scottish land ownership custom
where landowners have been
long referred to as lairds,
the Scottish term for lord
with the female equivalent being lady."
On the purchase page, it states quote,
"Each lord title pack includes
a dedicated plot of land
measuring one square foot,
five square feet or 10 square feet,
a personalized title
certificate with your name
or the name of the title holder,
a unique plot number that will
be assigned to the title holder.
Your digital certificate will be emailed
to you within 24 hours.
We plant a tree for every order,
a digital personalized member's handbook."
Additionally, they have an
entire terms of service page
on the website as well,
with further detail.
Now, taking this all together,
there is an implication that by purchasing
a small plot of land
through Established Titles,
you become officially recognized
as a Scottish noble or lord.
They don't explicitly state that,
and in many ways they
explicitly walk that back.
And there's also, an implication of owning
a piece of Scottish real estate.
I'd call that ambiguous,
but we'll talk about that later.
Now, they do explicitly state
that you can buy a certificate,
that you get a dedicated plot of land,
and that they plant a
tree for every purchase.
Now, before digging into the claims,
let's clear a few things up.
Putting aside for the moment
whether Established Titles
makes any such claims,
can you become a lord or lady
through purchasing Scottish
land, novelty or otherwise?
No, not like this.
Now first off, I am
not a lawyer in the UK,
or a barrister, or a
solicitor, or an advocate,
or any of the other
strange words that they use
in the ridiculous English legal system.
- [Crowd] It's called soccer!
(clapping hands rhythmically)
It's called soccer!
- The entire idea of nobility
or listening to anything
that this guy says is silly
and quite frankly un-American.
But there is an authority
on this particular ridiculous subject,
that is the Court of the Lord Lyon.
Which deals with all matters relating
to Scottish heraldry and coats of arms.
And that court said, quote,
"Ownership of a souvenir
plot of land does not bring
with it the right to any description,
such as laird, lord or lady.
laird is not a title,
but a description applied
by those living on and around the estate,
many of whom will derive
their living from it,
to the principal landowner
of a long named area of land.
It will therefore be seen
that it is not a description
which is appropriate for the owner
of a normal residential property.
It cannot properly be used to describe
a person who owns a small part
of a larger piece of land.
The term laird is not one recognizable
by attachment to a personal name,
and thus there is no official recognition
of X-Y laird of Z.
The words lord and lady apply to those
on whom peerage has been confirmed,
and do not relate to
the ownership of land.
Ownership of a souvenir plot of land
is not sufficient to bring a person,
otherwise ineligible
within the justification
of the Lord Lyon for
seeking a coat of arms."
But what about that historic
Scottish land ownership custom
that Established Titles talks about?
Well, that's just wrong too.
A representative of the
Court of Lord Lyon stated
in response to another
Established Titles-styled company.
Quote, "The title, laird of
Glencairn would only apply
to the owner of the entire
estate if it exists,
not those buying one foot portions of it."
Now, you can become a lord
or lady through inheritance,
or marriage or royal decree,
but not from a Black Friday
sale from Established Titles.
A monarch can give a person a peerage,
such as a duke, marques,
earl, viscount or baron.
And sometimes people with
hereditary titles sell them,
usually because they
have financial problems.
These titles sell for tens
of thousands of dollars.
Okay, but what about the
implication of land ownership?
Do you own the land?
Now, again, putting aside the issue
of whether Established Titles
makes this particular claim
that you are actually buying the land,
are you actually buying the land?
Well Established Titles
has just under 200 acres.
Now, I looked around and rural land
in Scotland can cost
about $10,000 per acre.
Therefore, Established
Titles' several hundred acres
probably cost around $2 million.
And funny enough, Katerina Yip,
the CEO of Established Titles
also runs LandAssets.com,
which sells real land in Scotland
in one to two acre parcels.
Now, my guess here,
and this is just pure speculation,
is that they probably
buy up the land in bulk,
and either use it for Established Titles,
or sell it in slightly larger
chunks as actual real estate.
So with respect to the one
foot by one foot parcels,
no, you don't own the land.
It's too small to be
registered in Scotland
and get a deed for it.
Instead, you get a contractual dedication
from Established Titles.
This means basically nothing.
It's like buying an MP3 from Apple Music.
You have a contract that they will provide
a certain thing to you, a song.
Do you own it? No, no you don't.
Not in any real sense.
Now in this context, the Journal of
the Law Society of Scotland says, quote,
"There have been a few
articles in the media recently
about companies who were
selling off tiny pieces of land,
known as souvenir plots in the Highlands.
Some websites suggest that
ownership of the plot carries
with at the right to use the
title of laird, lord or lady.
Given that some websites claim
that the Land Registration
Scotland Act of 1979 removes
the normal requirements
to register your land,
thus permitting the sale to
take place under contract law,
the keeper would like
to clarify her position
on the subject."
A souvenir plot is defined
in the Land Registration
Scotland Act of 1979
as a piece of land which
being of inconsiderable size,
or no practical utility is unlikely
to be wanted in isolation except
for the sake of mere ownership,
or for sentimental reasons,
or commemorative purposes.
The keeper is required
to reject an application
for registration in the land registry
if the land to which it relates meets
the description of souvenir plot.
However, the fact that the keeper
is obliged to reject the registration does
not necessarily mean that ownership can
be obtained by some other means.
A real right of ownership
in land in the sense
of a right that is enforceable
against third parties
can only be obtained by
registration in the Land registry,
or by recording a deed in
the Register of Sasines as appropriate.
Solicitors who are consulted by a client
in relation to the purchase
of a potential souvenir plot
should bear in mind that in some cases
the land in question might
not be of inconsiderable size.
In such cases, no exemption
from registration applies.
In other words, the Land Registry Act
that Established Titles relies on defines
a souvenir plot of land in
the context of the things
that the register of land
will necessarily reject.
It doesn't affirmatively mean
that a souvenir plot of land
is something the law
will actually recognize.
All it means is that it
won't qualify as real estate.
What you get at most is a personal right,
a contractual right against
the actual landowner
of Established Titles.
You do not get a real
ownership of interest.
That is you don't own the land.
Established titles is
make a contract with you
that they won't develop your
tiny portion of the land,
and will record your name in
their own private registry.
You know what? (laughs)
They're actually making land NFTs.
That's basically what they're doing.
And then next there's a question
of does Established Titles
plant the trees that they claim?
Well, sort of, yes.
The very first headline on the website
is Save the Scottish Woodlands.
They also report to plant
a tree with every purchase.
Many people have assumed that this means
that the company is planting a tree
on the tiny plots of land
that is assigned to them.
I mean, if you read
through the entire website,
it becomes clear that this isn't true.
Established Titles donates money
to third parties who plant trees.
Now their website is replete
with pictures of forests,
and lists several addresses that appear
to correspond to wooded land in Scotland.
And I have no reason to
believe that this is false.
Now, for several years the
Established Titles website said
it had donated over 42,000 pounds
to these tree planting services.
But suddenly in late November 2022,
they changed their website copy to reflect
that they were responsible
for over two million trees being planted.
Now, it's clear when
you look at the language
that they work with third parties
who specialize in tree planting.
Now there's nothing
inherently wrong with that.
And in fact, you'd probably
want that delegation of labor.
These services could probably
plant trees much cheaper
than anybody else.
Except that the language
that Established Titles
uses is often misleading.
In fact, the CEO admitted that
the language was misleading,
especially when modified by YouTubers.
- I think we'll have
to like rephrase that,
or look at what we're saying
and try to make it clearer.
- Okay, but let's go
off on a quick tangent,
if you'll indulge me.
Let's talk about how much money
does Established Titles make?
Well, the answer I think is a lot.
Established Titles is currently owned
by a venture capital firm based
in Hong Kong called Galton Voysey.
It's this company that was reaching out
to YouTubers to do sponsorships
for Established Titles.
Now, I've talked to many creators
and I know that Established Titles
was sometimes paying five and
six figures for sponsorships.
For the bigger YouTubers
with bigger views,
sometimes 75,000 to
over $100,000 per video.
Sadly, they only offered
me $7,000 per video,
and my friend Rowan, who is
a cardiac surgeon, 3,500.
So you know the lawyers win again.
But as it happens, your boy
here isn't just a lawyer,
he's also a content creator
who runs sponsorships,
and is an expert in the creator economy.
So let's dig in.
Let's make some educated guesses about
the business of Established Titles.
In response to all this backlash,
the CEO of Established
Titles wrote a letter
to creators, quote, "Galton
Voysey has supported us
since day one, even though they knew
that their initial funding
for this conservation project
would most likely lead to financial loss.
This year alone, Galton Voysey has made
a multimillion dollar loss
on Established Titles.
Sponsoring all those videos isn't cheap."
And you know what? She's right.
Those sponsorships are expensive.
They've sponsored hundreds of videos
to the tune of four, five,
and six figure deals.
So let's talk about profit or loss.
I'm a little bit skeptical here.
Now, as I mentioned,
Established Titles boasts
of over two million trees being planted
in response to their business.
We know that the upper limit of
the cost per tree is $1 per tree.
That figure comes directly
from One Tree Planted,
the company that Established Titles works
with to plant trees.
Now, I have no reason to think
that either the 42,000
pounds being donated,
or the two million trees numbers is wrong.
I suspect that they realize
that two million trees sounds way
more impressive than 42,000 pounds.
So they change the language on
the website to reflect that.
That makes sense.
But because of that, I think
we can easily figure out
how much of a cash cow
Established Titles is.
They say that they're responsible
for over two million trees.
We know that it costs at most
$1 per tree and probably less.
Now, the minimum that you can spend
on Established Titles is $50
for a digital only certificate.
If you wanted that printed
out and shipped to you,
that costs an extra $30.
If you want that piece of paper framed,
that costs an extra $59,
for a total of $139.
Now you can also buy larger
plots of land for more money.
But at least the printing
out, and the certificate,
and the frame upsells cost
$30 and $59 respectively,
with hundreds of dollars in extra upsells
if you want want five or
10 square foot packages,
or a couple's package.
Then at the checkout page
you're automatically signed up
for an $8 recurring charge
to plant one tree per
month until you cancel.
Now as an aside, I found
this automatic addition
to my cart to be particularly gulling,
because the language makes it sound like
it's the tree planting
that is already included
with your purchase.
In other words, when I was checking out,
and yes I did purchase
one of these things,
I thought they listed
the tree with every order
in my cart as a separate item.
I had to read the small print to realize
that this was an upsell of
a monthly recurring $8 cost
for one tree being planted every month.
Now the fact that they have planted
over two million trees
means that they've made,
approximately, two
million individual sales.
Now, granted this number might be off
if they made a separate
donation of trees on their own,
but if they had, they'd
probably be shouting it
from the mountain tops.
And admittedly, that
upsell of a monthly tree
will drive that dollar
per sale number down.
So let's be extremely conservative,
and say that there are two trees per sale.
In other words, two million
trees being donated means
that they've sold at least
one million individual sales.
So to figure out the revenue and profit,
you can generally multiply the number
of sales roughly two trees per sale
by how much they make on each sale.
So how do we figure that out?
Well, given that the
minimum that you can spend
on a digital certificate
that costs zero marginal dollars is $50,
and the sheer number of upsells
that also cost almost
zero marginal dollars,
I think that the average cart value
is easily $100 plus.
Now factor in fulfillment
of maybe a couple dollars per order
for a cheap frame in shipping,
then take some off the top for overhead.
Then the biggest expense is
marketing the sponsorships.
Now, it's not unusual to
spend 30 to 50% of revenue
on marketing for a high margin,
instant profit product like this.
And then they probably
spent about $2 million
on 200 acres in Scotland.
All told they're probably
looking at revenue
of roughly $100 per purchase,
and a net profit of
about $50 per purchase.
Yes, that probably means that over
the last three years they have revenue
of roughly $100 million,
with profit easily exceeding $50 million.
But look, that's just a guess.
My assumptions could be wrong.
You can do the math yourself.
But at base I think Established Titles
is wildly profitable with a
large expense being marketing.
But the benefit of that marketing
is that you can easily
scale it up or down,
and make instant profit.
And they could easily be making $2
for every $1 that they spent.
They clearly make a large margin
on every single sale that they make.
And there's even a plaque.
On Galton Voysey's office
tour in their website.
We see that even as far
back as 2020 and 2021,
before this huge boom
in YouTube sponsorships,
Established Titles was regularly making
over a million dollars
in quarterly profit,
and it was their most profitable company.
So now we get to the heart of the matter.
Does Established Titles engage
in false or misleading advertisements?
Their website states right in
front, "Become a Lord Today."
And that's not technically
true. You can't become a lord.
The implication is that Established Titles
has found this one weird trick,
this funny little legal loophole
that lets you become Scottish nobility.
But implications are not
necessarily false advertising.
And there is subsequent language
that claws this back
further down on the website.
And they say that it's based on,
but not necessarily following
an ancient Scottish custom.
And they say that it's a purchase
for a personal dedication
for a souvenir plot of land.
And you may choose to title yourself
with the title of lord, laird or lady.
And it's true that they will dedicate,
whatever that means,
a plot of land to you.
They imply that you own the land,
though they don't outright say that.
And that historic custom
language is weird though.
Where landowners have been
long referred to as lairds,
the Scottish term for lord,
with the female equivalent being lady.
I mean in what sense? You're
not really buying the land.
So why is this custom even relevant,
or being displayed on the website?
I mean obviously, we know why it's there,
but syntactically, what is it doing?
But look, there are good
arguments on both sides here.
From Established Titles' side,
the purchaser does get
certain rights related
to their plot of land.
Yip explains that should
Established Titles ever attempt
to sell the land that your square foot
is on you can sue them.
While you don't actually get a deed
or a plot registration
by possessing some contractual
rights over the square,
you do, to some degree, own that land.
Now the bit about becoming
a lord is a fun premise,
but it's pretty silly once you realize
that it would mean that literally anyone
that owned land in Scotland
would be a lord or a lady,
which doesn't make any sense.
- Well, it's a well known fact, Sunny Jim,
that there's a secret society of
the five wealthiest
people in the world known
as The Pentaverate who run everything
in the world including the newspapers.
And meet tri-annually at
a Secret Country Mansion
in Colorado known as, The Meadows.
- But that leads into
one of the best defenses,
which would be that it's
so ridiculous on its face
that no one would be confused
about what they were buying.
No one seriously thought
that they were actually going
to become Scottish nobility.
- Ah, I hated the colonel
with his wee, beady eyes!
- And their website is pretty clear
about implying a real noble title,
but never actually saying it.
And then, you know, having lots and lots
of disclaimers to claw that back anyway.
But it's funny, you know,
once I started researching
Established Titles,
I started getting tons
of targeted advertising.
And in this case, it was
actually very helpful.
In these two targeted ads that I received,
there were even bigger gaps
between what was advertised
and what consumers were actually getting.
- [Wife] When you buy land in Scotland you
are legally referred to as a lord or lady.
So this, I bought a square foot of land,
where they're gonna plant a tree.
(husband laughs)
So you are legally
referred to as Lord Liam.
- The advertisement state
with zero qualifications
that you will own a specific unit of land
in Scotland with your
purchase and become a lord.
That advertisement has nothing
about getting a contractual
right to a dedication.
And the ad also implies causation
between buying a piece of land, false,
and then becoming a lord, also false.
But in fairness, Established Titles' terms
and conditions clarify these claims
on the website in small
prints saying, quote,
"The purchase of a title pack
from Established Titles
does not constitute
or trigger a transfer of
ownership over that souvenir plot
or any part of the land
in the legal sense."
And the website also describes
this lord package as quote,
"A fun novelty product."
Though it is pretty sneaky
that they titled their products
a Lordship package and a Ladyship package,
without actually bestowing
a lordship or a ladyship.
But the website also describes
these packages as quote,
"A fun novelty product
that the purchase is a personal dedication
for a souvenir plot of land.
And the individual quote may choose
to title yourself with the
title of lord, laird or lady.
But arguably these disclosures contradict
the plain text to these ads,
which say that you will own Scottish land
and you will become a
lord with your purchase.
And contradicting the plain
text of an advertisement
is a no-no when it comes
to false advertising.
And furthermore, the ad's inclusion
of a formal certificate
gives the impression
that a person buying a certificate
will literally be a lord
or lady of Scottish land.
But hold on, because some
of their ads are even worse,
and I have the receipts.
More on that in a second.
And a lot of people have noted
that Established Titles'
business evokes comparisons
with the famous register of Star Company.
Where basically you're
just paying this company,
so you can put your name associated
with some star in, again,
a private registry.
Not the official place where
stars are actually named.
But while a person literally can't own
a piece of the galaxy,
becoming a lord is a real thing
that you can do in real life.
And again, the clear implication
of Established Titles' advertisements
is that if you pay them money,
you will literally
become a lord or a lady.
And in fact, in the FAQ section
of Established Titles' website,
the company encourages purchasers to refer
to themselves as lords or
ladies on official documents,
including credit cards
and airline tickets.
Now I got a hold of the creator brief
that Established Titles gave
to various YouTube creators
when they were running
Established Titles sponsorships.
And in that brief Established
Titles says specifically
that the creator can't say
that you can change your name
on your passport or when
applying for bank loans.
And as the CEO confirmed in
an interview the reason is,
because there isn't a dropdown menu
when you're choosing your
options on a passport.
In most common law jurisdictions,
you can title yourself,
however you wanna title yourself,
as long as you're not well,
as long as you're doing it in good faith,
and you're not using it
to try to get a bank loan.
Or try to get someone
to invest like way more
than they would've, you
know, trying to make
yourself seem trustworthy,
and make someone else basically
give you funds for that
by using the word sorry,
using the lord or lady title.
But if you're doing it in good faith,
if you're putting it
on like a plane ticket,
or a credit card,
you can technically call yourself,
whatever you wanna call yourself.
Rather, sorry, very specifically,
you can title yourself however
you wanna title yourself.
- But if it's not actually possible,
why you need to warn
people not to do that?
And then they say that you can't do
it when applying for a bank loan,
because you can't seem to be
more trustworthy than you are,
and you can only do things in good faith.
But under one circumstances
can you ever say
that you are a lord or a
lady in good faith based
on Established Titles' products.
It's either a joke or a gimmick,
or you can do it in good
faith, it can't be both.
So that takes us to the defenses.
Established Titles has vigorously
pushed back against claims
that it has engaged in false
or deceptive advertising,
and is otherwise a scam.
And admittedly, they have strong defenses.
After Scott Shafer's video
on November 24, 2022,
the founder of Established
Titles, Katerina Yip,
sent a letter to creators.
And she described the package
as a fun gift meant for a good laugh.
Miss Yip further states that its consumers
to understand that they
aren't literally becoming
a Scottish lord or lady.
Suggesting any belief to the
contrary would be unreasonable.
Quote, "We have always been
clear that our certificates
are based on a historic Scottish custom
of calling landowners
lairds, lords or ladies.
And that it does not grant
you the right to rule,
or make you a member of any royal family,
nor the right to a peerage."
And there's no doubt that
a lot of people saw this
as a gag gift, and therefore did not buy.
That's not false advertising.
That could be described
as accurate advertising,
and people making a reasonable
decision not to purchase.
Now, a friend of mine who ran
an established title spot,
explained it like this.
Quote, "I'm sure from
a lawyer perspective,
you're pulling your hair out
at the, you can own land claim.
But I think the rest of us think
of this as a silly gimmick,
a feature or bug of late stage capitalism
where people are looking to
spend their disposable income
on weird like feeling a part
of some souvenir plot of land
in a beautiful far away
place that feels formal,
and is potentially contributing
to some preservation effort.
But I honestly don't even think
the conservation thing is even an appeal.
People find value in weird stuff.
And again, I don't think anyone
is earnestly purchasing Established Titles
through any of their competitors.
Yes, there are several it appears
thinking they now own land
and are literally a lord.
If anyone is selling it like
that I agree that's misleading.
But it's hard to call
Established Titles snake oil,
or scam when it's so
clearly a silly gimmick."
Now, I think this is a totally
fair way of looking at it.
And it's an interpretation that buoyed
by all the disclaimers on the
Established Titles website.
A lot of the critics of
Established Titles saw no value
in purchasing from Established Titles,
and therefore didn't purchase.
But they then assume that
everyone who did purchase
must have been a complete
idiot, and been misguided.
But I think my friend's
interpretation recognizes
the agency of the buyers
and the value propositions
of Established Titles.
And all that is totally reasonable.
And in a November 2022 interview
with a British YouTuber,
Katerina Yip states
that Established Titles
has always classified
this lord, lady package as a novelty item.
- We've always been very
clear on the website
that this is a novelty item.
And I think that
the language really hasn't
changed since day one.
- But there are some
problems with this defense.
In that brief they include a section
on common errors to avoid.
And section two says, quote,
"The phrase royalty or nobility.
Our certificate is based on
a historic Scottish custom
of calling landowners
lairds/lords or ladies.
It does not grant you the right to rule,
or make you a member of any royal family.
Our certificates also do
not grant you peerages
of the United Kingdom."
Now first, I think that
there's an argument to be made
that the reason that they have
to tell creators not to say this is,
because they know that they're creating
a lot of confusion in the marketplace.
Now, arguably people have been misled.
It also undercuts the argument
that the term lord is ambiguous.
In general, I think it
would be a good defense
to say that lord or lady is
an ambiguous term subject
to multiple definitions,
one of which Established Titles meets.
But I think most people understand it
to mean the nobility
associated with peerage,
which Established Titles tells creators,
specifically, not to say.
Though, on the other hand,
this is also evidence
that Established Titles is being careful,
and affirmatively avoiding confusion.
But a second problem with this defense
is that the content creators
who have been sponsored
by Established Titles often
use the word officially,
or real in the context of the lordship,
as in officially a lord.
Or now, I'm a real lord,
- [Narrator] Thanks to an
old Scottish custom means
that you or the person you're
buying the land for officially
becomes what's known as a laird.
That's a lord or lady for
us modern English speakers.
- You could officially
become a lord or a lady, too.
- I am a 100% authentic Scottish lord.
- [Influencer] This official
certificate making you
a real lord or lady.
- I think they use that language,
which is not included
in the talking points,
because that's kind of what
it seems like they're selling.
And I suspect that they
were confused and/or misled.
And like all sponsors
Established Titles has a duty
to supervise the sponsorship integration,
at least the part of the video
that they have specifically sponsored.
And according to the
creators that I've talked to,
they do review every
video before it goes live.
This is because companies
are legally responsible
for the portions of the
videos that they sponsor,
and the words that those
creators say in that context.
In other words, when a creator
says Established Titles
will make you a real lord,
or you'll officially become a
lord, they own that language,
even though it's arguably contrary
to the provided talking points.
Some sponsorships lean into
the conservation aspect.
But a lot of the
sponsorships on YouTube focus
on the lordship and many go hard
on becoming official or real.
In fact, the CEO admits that this
is the main criticism of people
is that the titles are
not official titles.
And yet, tons of creators use those terms,
and use that kind of language.
But where could those creators have gotten
that wrong idea from?
Well, remember that I mentioned that there
were some even worse, more
dubious Established Titles ads?
Well, here you can see that
Established Titles does
in fact use the language
of official lordship
and legal lordship pretty often.
- [Wife] When you buy land in Scotland,
you are legally referred
to as a lord or lady.
So this I bought a square foot of land
where they're gonna plant a tree.
(husband laughs)
So you are legally
referred to as a Lord Liam.
- Can you guess how I became
a lord at just age 19?
- No.
- I would probably have to guess
that you inherited the position,
because of your father before you.
- Actually Established
Titles sells a title
that can officially make
you a lord or a lady.
On top of this, since you're
officially a lord or a lady,
you have dedicated land in Scotland.
You will literally get a certification
that makes you a lord or a lady.
Pretty cool, right?
- Yeah.
- (laughs) I'm a lady!
I have land in Scotland!
- I love it! I've always
wanted to be a lady.
- I'm a lady!
- Hat tip to Scott Schafer
for finding some of those ridiculous ads.
And they consistently say that
you officially become a lord,
or that you are legally
a lord, no disclaimers.
So while in general established title says
that you can refer to yourself as a lord,
and maybe the term lord, laird or lady
is open to interpretation.
Claiming that you are officially
a lord, or legally a lord
is quite another stronger
claim altogether.
Now, I suspect there are a good number
of people who read the
Established Titles website or ads,
and thought, yes, noble titles are silly.
But according to this legal loophole,
I can be a real noble, too.
And if true, that could have been
the result of misleading advertising.
In part, I know this because
Established Titles blog
specifically says, quote,
"You won't believe this
legal loophole in Scotland."
I mean, I guess technically that's true,
because I don't believe them.
But they go on, quote,
"There's a small legal
loophole in Scotland
that makes it possible for anyone
to title themselves as lord or a lady.
Through this loophole
anyone can buy a small plot
of land in Scotland
and refer to themselves
as a lord or a lady."
Furthermore, stating that your product
is a novelty on the website
doesn't necessarily cure
the issue of Established
Titles' advertising campaigns
that suggest you
literally become nobility.
And as the FTC has made very
clear, you cannot advertise
in one way and have disclaimers
that say something else on your website,
particularly if you have
to scroll to find it.
Now, perhaps it's true
that absolutely no one
thought they were a real lord or lady.
But given Established
Titles' marketing campaigns
and the sponsored creators who suggests
that this is anything but a novelty,
I definitely wouldn't hang
my hat on that defense.
Now, another defense in
Established Titles' favor
is that people accurately
view this purchase
from Established Titles as
a pro-conservation gift.
And as far as I can tell, you do get
at least one tree planted
with every purchase.
They probably have purchased
200 acres in Scotland.
They do work with third
party tree planting services,
which appear legitimate.
You're not getting
nothing for your purchase.
You are contributing
to environmental causes
with a cheeky nonsense nobility
thing thrown in for kicks.
The CEO explains what they actually do,
which isn't necessarily a bad thing,
buying land and then
contracting to never develop it.
But when asked about consumer confusion,
the CEO waffles for almost a full minute,
trying to dance around
all of the confusion.
- Do you think that there is
a little bit of unclearness
in terms of what it is?
Because essentially you guys are
the lords and ladies of that land.
You're the ones who own it.
So do you think there is a
little bit of misunderstanding,
or miscommunication do you
think maybe to the audience as
to what their true status
statuses around that?
Because I feel like a part of it does rely
on individuals knowing
the laws around this,
and not everybody does.
I certainly didn't. (laughs)
- That's a really fair question.
So I think we're very clear about that.
In our FAQs we talk about
how souvenir plots work,
and how we take our obligations
to our lords and ladies very seriously.
So I wouldn't say that we are the,
like lords and ladies of the land.
We are the title holders.
That's a thing, like legally.
We can't do what we want with it. (laughs)
So you know, now that we've
contractually entered, sorry,
now that we've entered into
a contractual obligation
to specific people.
The stuff that normally
let's say flows with owning
or being the title holder of a plot,
purely doesn't apply here.
I understand what you're saying about
it perhaps...
are the customers, the real
owners if you own the title.
But I think the way we see it
is we take our contractual
obligations extremely seriously.
- Now I commend this YouTuber
for engaging in this interview
and trying to do the research,
and going back to the source,
and actually getting
firsthand information.
But even she admits that it's confusing,
and that they're aware
of others being confused.
And that Established
Titles needs to update
the talking points
because they're confusing.
- I just think that that's
probably one of the parts
that's a little bit confusing.
'Cause there's some people,
I mean, even people who
may have purchased through myself,
who has felt like, "Oh, I thought
like there might have been
like even if I can't really use it,
there might have been a little
bit of legitimacy behind it."
- Now I've seen a lot of people
criticize Established Titles
saying that if you really cared
about environmental causes,
you would just skip
Established Titles altogether
and donate directly.
Now I'm of two minds about this.
Because first of all, that's
not how charity works.
Sometimes you have to throw a party
that costs a million dollars
to entice guests to donate $3 million.
You might not like the
waste, or the inefficiency,
but sometimes you need a reason
to incise people to give.
And established title CEO said quote,
"In the past two years, we
have done more tangible work
in the preservation of
the woodlands in Scotland
than anyone else to our knowledge.
This includes donating to
plant over two million trees,
and acquiring over
hundreds of acres of land,
and contractually committing
to preserve it in its natural state.
This year we are slated to
be Trees for the Future's
Giving Tuesday partner,
matching all donations up to $50,000.
It's a shame that this
attempt to cancel us
will make these efforts in
the future that much harder."
Okay, sure. but let's talk
about orders of magnitude here.
Now, as I said before,
I'm guessing that the average
card value is about $100.
It costs a maximum of $1
per tree to plant a tree.
So you're talking about roughly
one to 2% of the revenue
of this company going to tree planting.
The less than 200 acres
that Established Titles owns
is roughly 0.3 square miles,
not three square miles, 0.3 square miles.
In a part of Scotland that doesn't see
that much development anyway.
So let's be real here.
Established Titles is far more
of a money making venture
than it is an environmental charity.
So is Established Titles a scam?
I mean, it seems like it,
at least colloquially.
A scam is defined as a
dishonest scheme, a swindle.
So probably, it seems like
there's some dishonesty there.
Is it illegal?
Well, there are some good
arguments to that effect.
And look, Established Titles
is not the only one out there.
There's a million of
these different companies,
highlandtitles.com,
Scotlandtitles.com, all dreck.
And defenders have said it's only as much
of a scam as the name a
star registries or NFTs,
to which I say, "Correct."
Most of those are scams as well.
And the funny thing is,
on the internet everyone
always screams class action lawsuit.
And class action lawsuit never makes sense
in the context that people think it does.
But here, if people were deceived,
that is exactly the kind of thing
that actually would
work as a class action.
Except buried in the small
print in the terms of service
on establishedtitles.com is
a class action arbitration waiver.
Though I do question whether
that would be enforceable in this context.
And even if it's not outright illegal,
it's terrible for creators at large.
Some creators in the wake of apologizing
for running an established
title sponsorship have admitted
that they will basically
take any sponsorship
that comes their way.
- I get a sponsorship
opportunity for almost anything,
I'm gonna take it.
- And that's the creator's right.
They can run whatever
sponsorship they want to,
or decide not to run whatever
sponsorship they want to.
But the thing is,
it hurts the entire creator economy,
because when very prominent
YouTubers promote crap,
everyone assumes that all
the sponsorships are crap.
And I've seen lots of
comments to the effect
that the viewer just automatically assumes
that everything any YouTuber
promotes is just dreck.
And that's not fair to the people who
are running legitimate sponsorships.
And to that point, look,
my sponsors are legitimate.
If I say that I use them,
I actually use them.
And not to be holier than thou,
but I'm represented by Nebula Talent,
and full disclosure, I'm
a large minority owner.
But literally no one
represented by Nebula talent ran
an Established Titles sponsorship.
Now fair, Established Titles
riseable was on its face,
but at the same time,
the CEO of Nebula Talent, Dave Whiskus,
has kept telling everyone
not to burn their reputation
on what was at best a
gimmick or a gag gift.
Because once you lose your credibility,
you never get it back.
And there's not just reputational risk,
there's also counterparty risk.
And wouldn't should know it?
Established Titles has now pulled all
of their sponsorships for 2022,
because of all of this backlash.
They're actively breaking
contracts they had with creators,
though at the same time they're
also letting creators out of
their contracts if they want.
So it was good while it
lasted. I hope it was worth it.
But look on the bright side,
there's always Raid: Shadow Legends.
But it's been a long day at the office,
and all this talk of scams
and fake environmental
charities has me wishing
that there was a way to know
which charities were worth it,
and how to maximize my donation dollar
to do the most good possible.
(digital scratching wavers)
If only there was a way to do that.
Well, luckily there is.
Today's legitimate sponsor
GiveWell does exactly that.
Give Will spends over 40,000 hours
each year researching
charitable organizations,
and only recommends a few of
the highest impact evidence-based
charities that they found.
Over 100,000 donors have used GiveWell
to donate more than $1 billion, with a B,
and ensure that their donations
have made maximum impact
to save tens of thousands of lives,
and improve the lives of millions more.
And here's the best part,
GiveWell is completely free.
GiveWell helps allocate
your tax deductible donation
to the charity that you
choose without taking a cut.
They publish all their
research and recommendations
on their site for free,
no signup required.
And when you donate through
GiveWell your donations
are still tax deductible in the US.
And they'll match your
donations up to a $!00.
GiveWell's top recommendation is to donate
to their all grants fund,
which can be allocated to any grant
that meets their cost effectiveness bar.
And my recommendation is to
give their Top Charities Fund,
which direct donations to
the charity or charities
that GiveWell has determined to be
the most effective each quarter.
GiveWell is transparent about
how donations are spent,
and how their decisions are made.
They even have a webpage
devoted to sharing
the mistakes that they've
made along the way.
GiveWell simplifies the process of finding
and giving to outstanding charities,
because they do the independent research.
They give me peace of mind
that my donations will do
the maximum good, because
they've done the research.
And this is incredible.
GiveWell is matching donations
from first time donors,
dollar for dollar up to $100.
Just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to donate.
And on the donation page, when asked
about where you heard about
GiveWell choose YouTube,
and Legal Eagle.
Or again, to have up to $100 matched,
just click on the link below.
And after that click on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.